what is wrong with just charging hourly
okay I'm teing for Lay thank you what's
what's the problem with hourly pricing
uh so like a day rate that seems cool I
mean I I I did a video about this that I
I actually truly believe that hourly
rate charging is unethical right and the
reasons for this is so imagine if you
did want to go and get a website done
for example uh well maybe maybe you're
you're doing a beauty parade and there's
three web designers okay so web designer
number one comes along Aly and he says
to you I can build your a website I'll
do everything you want to do um it's
going to take me 10 hours um uh and I'll
charge you £100 an hour for it so about
£1,000 and you think okay cool uh so he
goes away what he forgot to tell you
though was he's not been doing it for
very long uh he's not particularly good
at it uh because he's not charging
enough he's taken on too many clients so
he comes back eventually about five
months later um with a bit of a hack
together sort of website it doesn't have
the blog or the shopping cart on there
that he promised you and what do you say
where's my blog of my shopping cart and
and can you add them and he says well
yeah I can add them on but it's going to
cost you another 5 hours and you're like
okay but I thought you told it me it's
going to take 10 and and so he
reluctantly agrees he says okay well I
I'll just build it now you're annoyed
that he's you know at one end of the
spectrum as a customer uh he's now a bit
like you know reticent cuz like he's not
getting paid what he thinks he's worth
because now he's doing work for free
effectively yeah um most people are like
ethically morally upstanding human
beings and they wouldn't just tag on the
extra money but the mere fact that could
tells me that hourly rate charging is a
broken business model okay so there's
our first clue that it hourly rates
don't work right web designer number two
comes along right so he says to you he's
more experienced he says Ally uh could
build your website in in 30 days um
it'll have everything which you want on
it um and um uh I'm going to charge you1
an hour for it um but because I'm better
than the other guy I can do it faster so
it'll take me 5 hours to do it I'm
thinking well you're getting a good deal
as the customer but surely the guy who
can do it better and faster and deliver
better results why does he get paid less
than the guy who's less experienced and
is still learning and doing making a bit
of a hash of it so again tells you that
there's nothing unethical going on there
but it tells you that hourly rates is a
broken business model yeah the the
incentives are wrong here yeah so now we
get web designer number three comes
along it's absolute like website ninja
he says I'm going to build you the
website in 7 days have a shopping cart
uh it'll have the blog on there that you
want to to be able to edit all the
content yourself we'll get it connected
up to Google Store so your products will
be listed in there within about 14 days
um and we'll be selling your products
and uh by the way if we can't get you a
10x Roi on the investment you make with
us within the first 12 months we'll give
you your money back for that plus we'll
also pay you ,000 of wasting your time
which you can spend on the other two
people who are kind of playing at
it yeah that's someone I'd be like wow
this is like some some good energy cool
ask me how much how much is it 10K 10K
yeah let's go cool so but it's 10 times
the price of the other two if you think
about it yet because he's got a clear
idea about he's got he's got his process
processes down it's all systemized he
knows that he only works with you know
YouTube influencers for example so he he
only has one type of client service he
knows that he can I say he could be she
as well um that they can deliver
remarkable results and they can do it
predictably
um and therefore they can put that
guarantee in there they're going to
deliver you those results damn so the
value proposition is that much stronger
hourly rates don't exist in that
transaction even if it only takes that
person an hour to build it yeah nice so
if I were to started starting a
relationship coaching business I
shouldn't think hourly pricing is my
definely definitely not um it's got to
be based on the results which you
deliver for clients pure and simple hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye